[Música]
pronto será medianoche ahora de los
últimos preparativos para estos
activistas de la causa animal el
objetivo de esta noche volvemos al mismo
lugar de la semana pasada para sacar a
los dos individuos de los que habíamos
hablado para ellos los animales son
individuos que hay que salvar cuando
lleguemos nos estacionamos justo aquí
frente a esta entrada
así sólo debemos bordear el campo frente
a las certificaciones de ubicar as como
guardas tal como la última vez o dan lo
la hiper si aún no tienen 30 años pero
si una veintena de operaciones de
secuestro en su lista acciones ilegales
preparadas minuciosamente mucha
excitación un poco de temor
hay una cantidad de aspectos que hay que
dominar si no se trata de un juego a
nosotros en el peor de los casos nos
conduce en la detención preventiva pero
saldremos vivos pase lo que pase pero si
la misión fracasa estos dos pequeños
serán enviados al matadero tal como está
previsto
su blanco esta noche
un criadero de cerdos a 30 km para mí es
estupidez cuando los creadores dicen que
aman a sus animales
mis padres nunca me educaron para
asesinarme al final
[Música]
en la entrada
señor
danilo la se equipan
en árboles los colores de su movimiento
se dirigen a la sala de maternidad
como vemos estás marranas con la mirada
triste están desoladas encerradas siete
días de 7 y 24 horas al día en estas
celdas y es por ello que debemos hacer
algo al respecto
tenemos el deber de actuar contra algo
que es injusto es inmoral pero
desafortunadamente legal un poco más
lejos en la sala de engorde
indignados para ellos grabar ya no es
suficiente
[Música]
pero no
la proyección exterior
sí
en el derecho francés un robo de esta
naturaleza es castigado con una pena que
puede ser de hasta 10 años de cárcel
lo sabremos
estos pequeños cerdos serán confiados a
un refugio acostumbrado a las
operaciones nocturnas
[Música]
golpear los criaderos y ocupar los
mataderos 269 liberación animal hizo de
ellos su marca de fábrica en cinco años
este otro colectivo ha llevado a cabo 30
acciones con cara descubierta como este
bloqueo en el sureste de francia
de los 58 militantes 6 están siendo
procesados por la justicia la cabeza del
movimiento stefan la gao
esa noche no participó en la acción pero
es acusada de haber inspirado a los
bloqueadores es su 15º proceso con pena
en suspenso una nueva condena podría
conducir la prisión
hay temor porque no es un momento
agradable de andhra
pero al mismo tiempo se asumen 14 horas
de audiencia el veredicto se conocerá en
dos meses además de la cárcel
los acusados corren el riesgo de pagar
38 mil euros por daños y perjuicios ser
reclamados por el matadero hemos
escuchados por el tribunal y estamos
satisfechos ahora el tribunal decidirá
hará su trabajo es todo lo que tengo por
decir como considera la causa animal
solo diré eso
no me arrepiento asumo mi
responsabilidad es normal se trata de un
sistema de explotación de seres
vivientes entonces hoy más que nunca se
entiende que se trata de una lucha
esencialmente política y no sólo de
sensiblería frente a perros iba estamos
lejos de eso es pero en todo caso
en la región de parís donde los
incendios
se es criador desde hace seis
generaciones
esto es un criadero
pero no queremos abandonar así nos
cuesta no se sabe si todo irá bien si
hay animales enfermos si hay que luchar
te tiene que gustar estar en ello
hace 8 meses bruno vincent descubrió sus
inscripciones que establecen el vínculo
entre la cría y la epidemia es odio no
sé para ellos
es gente que ya no quiere este tipo de
crianza
es gente diferente no sé
quieren transformar el mundo no sé
bruno radicó una queja
pero no se hace ilusiones que no coman
carne pero que nos dejen tranquilos
a 250 kilómetros de allí consuelan su
compañero steve halaga dirige el
santuario
como un refugio para una cuarentena de
animales de esta altura
se puede hacer tenemos dos vacas que
vienen de laboratorios las ovejas y van
a la carnicería los cerdos lo mismo uno
que viene de un matadero también
deberíamos ver a los animales así y no
como pedazos de carne
con un puñado de fieles continúan la
lucha a pesar de los procesos así
tengamos procesos judiciales en bélgica
y en suiza o también en italia todavía
seguimos haciendo acciones en esos
países por lo menos el colectivo cuando
digo nosotros es todo el mundo
evidentemente una activista es activista
toda su vida finalmente en francia o en
el extranjero puede haber cosas que se
pueden saber y otras que no
la pareja planea abandonar francia para
vivir plenamente su revolución en nombre
de los animales